mikala and melania are both children of
a single god the offspring of queen
america and ratagan who we all know now
are the same being and as such they are
both emperians but suffered afflictions
from birth one was cursed with eternal
childhood mycola and the other harbored
a rot within melania mikola we know very
little about and we'll have to wait
potentially on more dlc to learn more
about him but what i do know is that
three percent of people who watch my
videos are actually subscribed which
makes me very sad so make sure to hit
that subscribe button so i can sleep
better at night thank you and here's
what i found while lore hunting on
mykola and melania the bewitching branch
description says the empyrean mykola is
loved by many people indeed he has
learned very well how to compel such
affection we can take from this that
mikola was either gifted at manipulating
others or was genuinely good-natured in
his intentions and what i've come to
believe is that the latter is true as
mykola created the hollow tree partially
out of love for his sister melania we
learn from ratagon's rings of light
incantation that mykola abandoned
fundamentalism or it could do nothing to
treat melania's accursed rot this was
the beginning of unalloyed gold meaning
mykola created the unalloyed gold needle
which held back scarlet rot in an
attempt to save his twin sister and
created the hollow tree to potentially
create a cure for scarlet rot since the
golden order and the er tree was found
incapable of doing so mykola melania in
the holic tree also appear to have
inspired devotion and loyalty in their
followers we gather this mostly from
item descriptions like the hollow tree
crest great shield and helm who have
vowed to serve nicolas holigtry we can
learn from the clean rot helm that these
nights were celebrated for their
undefeated campaign in the shattering
the clean rot knights vowed to fight
alongside melania despite the inevitable
if gradual future faction of their flesh
we can also learn from loretta's mastery
spell that the hollow tree was used as a
place of refuge for the albanorics
sorcery used by loretta knight of the
hollow tree developed by loretta after
her long bloody journey to seek out a
place where the albanorics could live in
peace loretta once a royal carion knight
went on a journey in search of a haven
for the albanorics and determined that
the hollow tree was their best chance of
eventual salvation i wanted to include
this information of loretta because it
tells us that she gave up her service to
the carrion royalty and devoted herself
fully to the hollow tree further telling
us that the hollow tree and the twins
stood for something that people greatly
believed in more so than the golden
order or the carrion royalty let's talk
about what we think happened to mykola
and melania after the shattering of the
elden ring melania fought her way
through the lands between to reach radon
on this journey she defeated godric but
decided not to kill him we know this
from a conversation we have with kenneth
height leslie godrick's nothing more
than a jumped up country bumpkin lord oh
don't make me laugh
first he hid himself amongst the women
folk to flee the capital then hid from
radon in that castle
then he insulted melania lost to her in
battle only to lick her boots rather
than die like a man we know that melania
and radon fought in caled where she
unleashed the full force of the scarlet
rot ending their great battle in a draw
between the two of them the description
of the ashes of finlay one of the clean
rot knights indicates that finlay
carried a slumbering melania back to the
hollow tree after the battle with radon
and as we can see from the world map a
journey from caled back to the hollow
tree is a very
long trip especially to carry a demigod
imperian so props to finlay who i'd
imagine was the strongest of the clean
rot knights we know mikala was taken
from the hog tree by moog and the hollow
tree is either already dying or begins
to die after mikola is taken from it
moog attempts to make mykola his consort
but fails and mykolo remains
unresponsive in his cocoon this cocoon
was clearly taken from this location at
the roots of the hollow tree where we
meet in battle against melania melania
was waiting here for mykolo's return
it's not clear but we can guess that
when we see her she's still deeply
sleeping and recovering from her battle
with radon i would assume that
unleashing the scarlet rot is very
exhausting it is also unclear if she
knows the nature of mikala's
disappearance from our battle with her
it seems as though melania is blind
since the scarlet rot appears to have
spread over her eyes this is just
speculation obviously there's nothing
that indicates that she is blind since
it really feels like she can see just
fine when she fights against us my flesh
was dull gold
and my blood
rotted
corpse after corpse left in my wake
as i awaited
his return the phrasing from her here
sounds as though she went out to fight
radon while waiting for mikala to return
it doesn't seem like she's leaving
corpses of soldiers in the hollow tree
while she waits for mykola and in my
wake i think is in reference to her
traveling to caleb finally we know at
some point mykola made a promise to
melania as we can tell from her armor
set which reads my brother will keep his
promise he possesses the wisdom the
allure of a god he is the most fearsome
emperian of all man i just know we're
going to fight mickeleh in some dlc or
hopefully we don't fight against him i
don't know he seems like a good guy all
i know is the the dlc of elden ring is
gonna be awesome this description could
possibly indicate something else but
it's likely just his general promise to
cure her of her scarlet rot so all of
this information leaves me with one
question why does melania decide to
fight radon maybe it was to acquire his
great rune but if that's the case why
would melania decide to spare godric is
it possible that just like with radon
the scarlet rot spreads to her brain and
makes her disillusioned with her
decision making though this also seems
unlikely since her devotion to mikala
seems to remain completely unwavered
it's also possible that she decided to
fight radon to stop him from holding the
stars at bay since most of melania's
intentions are in service of mykola it's
possible that mikla's destiny is held
back by the stars in some way just like
ronnie again all of this is speculation
let me know what you think down in the
comments but in my opinion i believe
melania was searching for mikala she
went on a long journey battling other
demigods in her search like godric and
was ultimately stalemated by radon and
was brought back to the hog tree to
recover so that she could go out again
and try and find mykla it seems to me
that mykola's disappearance was a
complete mystery we can see the
mannerisms of the hologree soldiers here
who seem to be searching for something
they're spread out randomly looking
everywhere in search of mykola if
melania and these soldiers knew that
mikala was taken forcefully from the
hollow tree by moog they'd likely be
more desperate to leave the hollow tree
in search for him to bring him back so
somehow
moog plucked the cocoon of mykola out of
the hollow tree and disappeared without
a trace now most people usually see
melania as the villain and radon is the
hero and while i still believe radon to
be a vitally important character in his
own ways and you should go watch my full
video on his lore if you want to know
more but i don't believe melania to be
this villain she nuked caleb with the
scarlet rot that's obviously bad and it
makes caleb and its inhabitants look
terrifying so we symbolize these scary
things with melania since she caused it
to happen but we should remember that
melania was born with this affliction
she didn't ask for it there's nothing
that indicates melania wants to be the
goddess abroad there's also nothing that
indicates that she wanted to take up the
throne and become queen like her mother
america she's constantly fighting a
curse that has nothing to do with her
and this curse is slowly destroying and
consuming her body i think that she just
loves her brother and wanted to help him
achieve his destiny in any way she could
and appreciated that someone wanted to
help her at all i really wish we knew
more about either one of these
characters and i think we are going to
know more once from software releases
more dlc in the future i still firmly
believe that we are going to touch
mikala's hand here in the mogwin palace
to access this future dlc but until then
we just don't know much guys i hope you
enjoyed the video thank you so much for
watching it all the way through make
sure to subscribe as 97 of people who
watch my videos are not subscribed which
again makes me sad so i'd appreciate it
if you did subscribe thank you have a
fantastic rest of your day and i'll see
you all in the next one
take care
[Music]
you